good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
actually Saturday but Tuesday me will be
on vacation so you're stuck with
Saturday me aka The Fault in Our Stars
movie came out in America yesterday me
aka the tiredest me I have ever been so
okay just briefly at the moment it looks
like The Fault in Our Stars is going to
be the number one movie in America this
week beating out movies that cost like
hundreds of millions of dollars to make
the reviews have been amazing and
according to Rotten Tomatoes 93% of
people who've seen it liked it so just
real quickly okay dramatic tonal shift
but forget to talk about books that are
not yet movies but should be on speaking
of course about behind the beautiful
forevers the book that we're reading
this summer in the nerdfighter book club
I want to start our conversation about
it today by talking about the first four
chapters so in this book we'll meet a
bunch of people who live in this slum in
Mumbai called annawadi now those of us
who don't live in slums tend to imagine
those who do rather monolithically but
it slowly becomes clear that there's a
lot of diversity in class and status in
annawadi
right like the life of the malnourished
garbage picker Sunil is very different
from the life of a med who buys and
sorts that garbage and very different
from Andrews life was aspiring to become
the first resident of on awadhi to
graduate from college so that's the
first and easiest level of complexity
that's added to our understanding of
life in places like on awadhi not all
poverty is equal and not all people
living in poverty are identical but it
becomes much more complex like we think
of government corruption as a cause of
poverty right and it often is but from
Andrews mother Asha it's also a way out
of poverty we think of empowering women
with loans from microfinance
organizations to be an engine that can
drive social and economic change in
communities and it can be but also
hoards and abuses microfinance loans in
order to get ahead I should add here for
all the nerdfighters who give loans by a
Kiva that that's why Kiva didn't work in
India until very recently and now does
so only with like crazy lots of
restrictions but anyway the complexity
that's most striking to me is that we
all think of funding schools as being
good and it is but Manju goes to a
charity funded college where one can
graduate basically by reading
CliffsNotes although to be fair that's
also the case with some American
universities for me the brilliance of
behind the beautiful forevers is that it
refuses to allow those of us who live in
the rich world to hide behind shields
like microfinance and charity and one of
my favorite passages a kid says
everything around us is roses and we're
the in between who goes on to write
about
condominiums and glass offices shooting
up all around on awanee a clear metaphor
for the roses the implication here I
think is that without manure roses can't
grow in order to have all of our
inexpensive consumer goods the rich need
the poor and we need them to stay poor
that's a very discomforting thing to
consider but we shouldn't look away from
it but then again as bhoot points out
almost no one weaving in on awadhi is
actually poor at least according to
official definitions sunil the garbage
collector may have to take puffs off of
discarded cigarettes to ward off hunger
pangs but he still lives on more than a
dollar 25 a day and when we say that a
hundred million people have emerged from
poverty in India in the last few decades
we're talking at least in part about
residents of ona Watty by many measures
life is better for people living in ona
wati than it would be without global
capitalism and this fantastic growth of
the over city this is a book that
resists reductive readings no matter
your ideology it gets challenged ok one
last thing it seems to me that in the
first 100 pages the greatest mover of
the narrative is not like corruption or
discrimination or ambition or any of
that but luck or fate I guess depending
on your world you but I mean the chance
of having your hand cut off while
working as a kid at a recycling plant
we're having a bum heart or an alcoholic
parent or being falsely accused of
assault as Abdul's father says your
little boat goes west and you
congratulate yourself what a navigator I
am and then the wind blows you East so
nerdfighters I'm interested what you
took away from the first four chapters
behind the beautiful forevers but I also
want to know what you think of look like
how do you make sense of a world where
luck plays such a huge role in your
triumphs and tragedies thanks for
reading the book with me Hank I will see
you on Friday